can you tell some of these stories that
stand out to you that are particularly
despicable or
representative or interesting when you
look back at that that defined your
approach and who you were at that time
let me say that I did not care about my
victim all right I cared about me is
what I cared about
um it's rough to it's rough to admit
that you know that uh you don't give a
[ __ ] what you're doing anybody else you
only care about you but that's that's
the truth of the matter I didn't care
about the victims
um the lady that was that wasn't even at
the beginning of my uh career as a cyber
criminal that was right at the last of
it I wish lady the coin lady I was uh by
that point Shadow crew had made the
front cover of Forbes August of 04
October 26th though for Secret Service
had to shut us down 33 people arrested
six countries in six hours I was the guy
that was publicly mentioned as getting
away
um what happened was I was the guy who
was uh
I had kind of invented this crime called
tax return identity theft and was
stealing a lot of money
I went through all my Stateside savings
and Shadow crew gets shut down I don't
have any way to come in with any money
so I start running counterfeit cashiers
checks
defrauding people without having them
send products or bullion collections
what have you by Cod collect on delivery
and I would pay with it with a
counterfeit cashiers check this lady was
on eBay
she had been collecting these silver
coins all of her life you know the U.S
currency used to be the coins used to be
silver so she had a whole collection of
these things like I don't know 80 90
pounds of this stuff and um
I'm a very good social engineer
so um convinced her that I was a
legitimate person that uh you know he
sent it to Cod you can use my FedEx
account to do that or my UPS account to
do that I'll pay with a uh cashier's
check you can take it in same as cash
she believed that she was even on the ad
and we talked on the phone and
everything else she had told me that she
would she was a single parent and it was
the only money that she had to uh
to put a roof on the house for Hunter
kids and uh I didn't give a damn I
didn't give a damn it what was more
important was me at that point can I ask
you a question about the social
engineering aspect so maybe specifics
like
the methodology email he said phone
maybe you could discuss this process
from a bigger philosophical perspective
of
what is it about human beings that makes
impossible to be social engineered to be
to be victims of fraud so
first let me say that that I became a
social engineer as a child all right
because the adults in my in my
environment as a child I had to know
exactly what they were thinking and be
able to try to manipulate that for
survival so I became a social engineer
as for for survival initially all right
and one of the things that I've seen
with a lot of cyber criminals is the
exact same thing the the really expert
ones they become a social engineer as a
child then later on they use those tools
to victimize others all right which is
fascinating because you're in order to
understand what others are thinking you
have to be extremely good at empathy so
you have to like really put yourself in
the shoes of the other person and yet in
order to do cyber crime you have to not
care
about the pain that might cause them
once you manipulate them so you have to
empathize and yet not care exactly and I
would argue I would argue that that is
not a sociopath because a cyber criminal
and I was no different most cyber
criminals justify those actions so the
justification becomes what's important
with me the justification was when I did
it for my family did it for my wife did
it from a stripper girlfriend yeah so
and I believed those jokes
because I care about love a lot yeah so
the the the big the big picture of that
is Trust
how do you establish trust with a
potential victim all right now I would
argue online that that trust is
established through a combination of
Technology tools social engineering all
right so we trust our Tech you know we
trust our cell phones we trust our
laptops a lot of times we don't
understand how they operate but we trust
the news that comes across the line we
trust the phone numbers that show up we
trust IP addresses if we're Advanced
enough to look at an IP address or a
domain or anything else like that
criminals use tools to manipulate that
spoot phone numbers boot browser
fingerprints
um or whatever that may be whatever the
tool might be
then that lays a base level of trust at
that point you shoot in with the social
engineering
and lay whatever story that is in order
to manipulate that victim to act not out
of reason but out of emotion all of a
sudden is this is fascinating about the
way humans interact
with the world which is
you're almost too afraid to not trust
the way you have to find a balance yes
you have a lot of sort of conspiracy
theories now about distrust institutions
and thinking like everything around us
it's like I've been listening to uh
people who believe the Earth is flat and
you know that that conspiracy theory is
fascinating to me because it basically
says that you can't trust anybody right
that like everything you hear is a lie
so that's one you know you can live that
life or you can live a life where you're
just naively trusting everything and we
as humans have to because that life is
kind of full of Happiness if nobody
screws you over right because you you
know you meet people with the joyful
heart and you get excited and all that
kind of stuff but if you do that too
much you're gonna get burned so you have
to find some kind of balance in terms of
optimizing happiness where you trust I
mean but verify and on the internet that
becomes really tricky you're almost too
afraid to distrust everything because
you'll never get anything done right on
the internet but then if you trust too
much you can get screwed over and so the
social engineering comes in where you're
like I'm not sure if I should trust this
you kind of help them build the
narrative was like it's good it's good
it's good so and a lot of the times that
social engineering is just feeding into
what the victim wants to believe yeah
all right it's it's not really coming up
with a brand new story at all it's just
knowing what that victim is what the
motivations of that victim is
feeding into it at that point so you
have to again that social engineer has
to almost immediately know what's
driving that person that they're talking
about if I'm so if I'm working on a
phone talking to someone over the phone
I have to know within seconds what I
need to say how I need to act to
interact with that customer service
agent or whoever I'm talking to on the
other end of the line so fascinating
because you truly are empathizing with
the other person
um what is it this business Mass doing
Schwartzman
um
uh I've talked a few times he he
mentioned this thing that you know
the way you build deep relationships is
you really kind of notice the things
that people are telling you like like
what what they want and uh what they're
bothered by what are their big problems
in their lives because everybody's
saying that all the time and most of us
are just ignoring it right you really
take the time to listen you know
somebody at that point yeah absolutely
you do then you have to be able to
dismiss it let's miss it after you know
you're you're looking for that just to
see how I can manipulate that is what
you're trying to do so that the lady was
one story The another truly despicable
story we'll get to script in a second
yeah but another truly despicable story
we had
we were one of the really first groups
that started phishing attacks was
sufficient so that is a social
engineering attack pH by the way yeah pH
that's another social engineering attack
that's sending that fake email out that
looks like it's coming from a website or
your financial organization or whatever
and saying hey we've got a security
problem we need you to update your
account information well back then
no one had ever seen a phishing attack
so you could ask for all the information
you were getting just complete identity
profiles on a phishing email nowadays
you can't do that nowadays you look for
basically credentials because everyone
is aware of phishing but back then it
was complete information we had fished
out I don't know 200 000 E-Trade
accounts that's what we have the login
password yeah login password complete
you know social date of birth mother's
maiden account information everything
else so we had access to those E-Trade
accounts E-Trade initially had no
security in place so you could cash out
the account ACH the money out to whoever
to whatever account you want to do went
through just fine ate them alive on that
for four to six months
E-Trade got to the to the point where
they you couldn't do any ACH coming out
you know you they locked everything down
well you're still sitting on thousands
of E-Trade accounts how do you make
money on that
hmm
it's a good question yeah so what you do
is you find some fat cat that's got his
retirement you know invested in Blue
Chips same time you find a penny stock
you open up a brand new account buy into
that penny stock cash the fat cat out
buy under that same penny stock
ing dump schemes all of a sudden so
you're destroying people's retirement
accounts for just a few thousand dollars
Bam Bam Bam and of course e-trade's
responses not our problem
it's your problem you shouldn't give up
your password or what have you at that
point and you still see that issue today
with Zell scams and things like that
azelle so you know the instant payment
that also the same kind of operations
with different uh mechanism you find an
easy way to exploit a system and
typically the financial organization not
our problem our system's secure it's the
humans it's their errors well not really
you know you've got some culpability in
that and you're just trying to avoid
paying the part of the bill that's
what's going on one of the things just
to stand fishing for a bit is uh
it really makes me sad because
there's been people on all kinds of
platforms like including YouTube
comments but emails too they figured out
emails somehow so people are
now seeing the followers
um of this particular podcast where fans
they're finding them on platforms like
LinkedIn and YouTube and so on and they
are figuring out ways to get to those
people by another channel right which I
suppose is it seems more authentic to
those people so they send them an email
from what looks like me
and with this kind like like loving me
it's the the interesting thing the email
sound like something I would write so
these aren't even at this stage it's not
even it doesn't feel automated or if
it's automated it's uh there's a human
in the loop that's really fine-tuning to
specific or maybe I'm very predictable
but it's very loving in the way I would
write a message well and and so so so
think about that all right so so when
fishing first comes out you could look
at the language of the text or the
website and say yeah if you if you were
paying attention that that's so okay so
that's not an English speaker who wrote
that typically all right but as as time
has went on as as the awareness of what
a phishing attack looks like we have
people that are sitting down now and
making sure that the language is proper
it gets worse than that though if you
look at business email compromise all
right so the way a business email
compromise typically works is the
attacker
we'll find a payroll person find a CEO
he will he will fashion a spear phishing
email which is that's a phishing attack
that's targeting one specific individual
all right so he'll fasten a spearfishing
email the way he does that is he pulls
all the information he possibly can on
that person all right that's CEO maybe
he'll
spear that CEO just to get their login
credentials to their email just to read
the emails and he'll go in there and
he'll start reading all these emails
he'll specifically read the emails to
the to the payroll department see what
that relationship is are they talking
about their kids talk about
relationships talking about vacation
what are they talking about how are they
talking are they friendly are they
sterile what are they doing all right so
then he decides well I'm going to go
ahead and Spearfish the payroll
department as well so then he spear
officials him gets those credentials at
the same time he creates a Unicode
domain and whatever the company name is
all right so instead of that English
alphabet I he's got that Russian letter
that looks like an eye but without the
dot on top all right comes back into the
email into the payroll email blocks the
real CEO's email replaces that with the
Unicode email that he's got and then
sends out
a message using the correct language to
correct relationships everything else
and says hey you know we're updating our
account status I need you to send this
payment instead of over here
they've set up a new account send all
payments over here now and that is
business email compromise in a nutshell
all right works great
probably the largest organization the
more susceptible to that kind of attack
because there's a
like a distribution of responsibility to
where you're more likely to believe that
okay this other person is responsible
I'm sure they they uh secured everything
absolutely I'm okay listening to this
so that that's business email compromise
and it's it those crimes and it's one
thing you see about cybercraft
cybercrime is not really sophisticated
it's not the attacks are not
sophisticated the stat is 90 of every
single attack uses a known exploit it's
not the stuff it's not zero day attacks
yeah they're out there but if you're a
criminal waiting on a zero day to profit
you're going to starve to death
the the meat and potatoes are that 90
known exploits and then the rest is well
you're saying it's uh maybe you mean
it's not technically sophisticated but
it's social engineering sophisticated
very sophisticated on that end very
sophisticated and it's a fascinating
study of that establishment of trust and
then using that trust to defraud that
victim that is something